I mean, Quentin, Tarantino's probably like this.
I don't know. Hard for celebrities to talk to their section,
to talk to media about their sexuality. This is Tom Hardy.
What on earth do you want about
referring to an interview given to attitude magazine a few years ago,
but what is your question? Nice. Oh, well.
Tom Hardy talking about somebody asked him about his sexuality.
And it's difficult for celebrities to talk about their sexuality.
I don't find it difficult for celebrities to talk about their sexuality. Um,
are you asking me about my sexuality? Um, Oh.
Wow. Just good actors in real life.
Act better than anything in the world.
Do you want about, but what is your question?
I was wondering if you find it difficult for celebrities to talk about their
sexuality.
I don't find it difficult for celebrities to talk about their sexuality. Um,
are you asking me about my sexuality? Oh, I'll get the guy crumbles. Sure.
Y Y slammed him. Thank you. Okay.
Oh, wow. Oh dude.
Yeah. That's so annoying, dude,
that people want to know if somebody's gay or not or whatever.
I would never tell anybody if I'm straight or gay ever in my life.
If somebody came up to me,
if I hope I get famous enough to where people are just like, Hey Chris, Leah,
what's up with your sexuality. I go like this, not talent,
not talent. Maybe I, maybe I make love to women.
And maybe I dudes all day long. I never tell you.
We need a straight guy to be straight secretly and
never talk about his sexuality and be like, no,
I would never talk to you about my sexual. I'm not, I'm not telling you.
And then we find out later he's married with kids and he was like, Oh,
that was like, Oh, we thought you were hiding it. You were gay. He was like,
why? My sexuality is none of your business. I'm a straight guy.
And I got kids and I'm married,
but I never would admit that because it doesn't matter. Slammed them.
As you were reading the script, did you ever.
Hollywood celebrities shutting down reporters.
And all these women in here? I thought this was supposed to be a man's movie.
No, no. For one minute
you, um, Robert Downey Jr.
The reason I'm asking you about the past is that you you've talked in other
interviews again about, um,
your relationship with your father and.
Oh boy, you could see he's already steaming.
Oh, okay.
The dark periods you entered and taking drugs and drinking and all of that.
And I just wondered whether, you know, you,
you think you're free of all of that or whether that's still something.
I really don't. What are we doing? Well, I'm just asking questions.
That's all right, bye.
I'm sorry. Oh man.
Just saying by, you know, he should have leaned forward and went.
That's what you should do when somebody asks questions. You don't want,
usually before you go like this
and don't even say anything and just wave your hand in their face.
Dude. Imagine,
imagine if you just saw somebody like.
Jackson, just yeah. So I would like to talk about, and he just doesn't.
He just goes until what are you doing? And then just get up and leave.
You just wave in their face. How for sake, dude.
I got to get so famous so I could do like that. You don't understand, dude,
I'm telling you right now. That's what I'm doing, dude. I can't wait.
You know what the worst name is? Hugh straight up.
The worst name on the planet is he'll. Do you know why it it's?
You it's not even a, it's like a sound.
You can basically say the name Hugh without even using your voice.
That's the name? That name sucks, dude. Hugh Hugh.
Hey, what's up? My name is.